[Music]
in beautiful county clare in the verdant
southwest of Ireland there is a man a
farmer a local legend a man who provides
a very special service that wants
someone that looks like Don and from
like I said it's special this great big
story is inspired by Genesis matchmakers
have been helping couples in Ireland
since ancient times and this guy is one
of the last my name is Witte daily I'm a
traditional Irish matchmaker what I do
is I find wives for advice and I find
husbands forget us matchmaking is a
traditional thing that stemmed from the
fact that in rural Ireland most
properties are left to a son and so the
girls are gone to Dublin or Europe and
America sometimes there's no girls
around so matchmaking was very essential
if someone lived in a rural place I
inherited matchmaking you know my father
was a matchmaker and my grandfather was
a matchmaker so I've been doing it over
50 years
[Music]
this is a low-key logbook you know it's
160 years or belong to my father my
grandfather and myself I have a little
forum people fill out a few details
maybe couple of likes dislikes only less
than at one page and some people fill up
very little on the page that just stay
open-minded the book I think it has
magic powers
so to touch the book with both hands and
you're single
you'll be in love and married inside the
six months and it seems to work in his
career Willie has brought quite a few
people together since I started I will
say it in the area of around 3,000 my
matchmaking hasn't changed in 50 years
my system with matchmaking his timing is
very important the pace you do the
matchmaking is important I love to
introduce people for physically contact
what that physical contact is often
created and enhanced by people drinking
a good lot and it makes them very happy
so my matchmaking has been our Guinness
as hell to the loss
I went into a house I used to frequent
today the matchmaking tradition has
evolved many matches are made at a
festival in nearby lists in Varna every
year the festival attracts thousands of
people and last 24 days
Willie is at the heart of the event and
to him human contact is everything you
can look into a woman's eyes and see the
beauty of the woman and be able to tell
her that sorry you can't tell and it an
eyesore a computer it's your loafers you
can't do that
this is Willie's daughter Elsa she's a
matchmaker as well
I think we can go on night now and go on
any of these I've said changer fancy
fish I have never done it so I don't
knock because I think it works for some
people but people just want originality
they want someone genuine and that's a
recommend
that's the white rover no one could
almost say everything has changed but I
can equally say that nothing has changed
people still have the same needs they
want someone to share their life with
share their walk with to get married
have children and enjoy a lovely happy
family night that's very important I've
never thought about not donors people
often say when you want to retire
and I suppose I do babe it's math died
several I'm too old to retire now
[Music]